because he has no consequences for
sleeping around that she also will have
no consequences for sleeping around and
what are the odds she does this right
after their wedding it's just weird
timing to me
um Adam I really hope you close this
marriage I really hope you
shut down I shut down the porn stuff
Adam in the name of helping women in the
name of being you know I think we should
come together on an anti-misogyny and
sexism women are sexualized all across
the nation women are are in such
horrible positions from Men in positions
of power from using and abusing us
um and just all of the blatant sexism so
you know I ask let's shut down the only
fans shut down the porn sites and stop
letting your wife sleep with other men
for money